welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this week
we're breaking down the most recent
entry in the MCU spider-man far from
home closed the door on phase 3 and set
up the future of the universe after the
events of Avengers endgame there's a lot
going on in the movie and throughout
this video I'm gonna be breaking down
the insane details within the film a
tie-in to other elements of the MCU I've
covered some of these aspects before but
just in case you haven't watched those
videos we'll be going through the ins
and outs of the entire film obviously
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to see the
movie yet then I highly recommend that
you war crawl your way out of here make
sure you subscribe to the channel
because we do break down cyclist every
day and please drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy the video without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
our breakdown of spider-man far from
home ok so the movie picks up in the
aftermath of avengers endgame tony's
absence is felt throughout the film
including drawings and classrooms at the
start murals on walls and pretty much
every city in the film is paying tribute
to him in some ways not only does tony's
memory linger over peter his image is
also used by Mysterio as one of the ways
that he manipulates the character before
making his quote-unquote sacrifice play
Mysterio mimics Tony Stark by snapping
his fingers to make Peter believe that
they are similar in their actions when
Peter drops the Edith glasses one of t
Mysterio picks him up and hands them
over highlighting that he's
irresponsible and will lose them
Mysterio also deliberately chooses a
very similar look to Tony Stark in the
first Iron Man movie he slicked back his
hair has a beard and upon donning the
Edith glasses could be mistaken for the
billionaire playboy this tricks Peter
into believing that in some ways he is a
younger version of Tony and it's one of
the main reasons he sees him as being
the true heir to the mantle Mysterio
traditionally looked like Spock from
Star Trek in the comics and when we see
the character and flashback he is
clean-shaven so he can assume that his
hair and beard choice were done on
purpose because he knew that Peter
looked up to Tony he also likely knows
that the character has been very close
to dr. strange
as they travel together to tighten an
infinity war Mysterio's magic -
resembles the runes that strange uses
which further influences the character
his arms also resembled those costume in
some ways as they have a very similar
texture and in the end credits we can
see that he did pull from the characters
design peter has mentioned that door
used to be a myth and that they now
study him in science class so he would
be aware of the character Beck had
clearly been following Peter for some
time and he actually appears behind him
in Venice after Peter goes to buy the
Black Dahlia necklace for MJ if he
jumped - 18 minutes and 15 seconds you
should be able to spot him on the
left-hand side of the screen stalking
the character he's not alone either and
throughout the scene we also see kutiman
who appears behind MJ and Peter as they
stroll along the canal we see later in
the movie that Goethe man is the
storyteller of the group that writes all
of the events that happen he drives the
bus for the class and escapes the kill
zone at one point even tipping his hat
to the students who he believes are
going to die there's also a blonde woman
that looks rather distinctive and we see
a pop up later in the movie as part of T
Mysterio so it seems like she's also
checking things out William Reaver also
appears and he's revealed to be a
scientist from Ironman this is Peter
Billingsley the kid from A Christmas
Story and he appeared in both movies
even shaving his head to be in the role
there's also several clues in the film
that everything is not as it seems long
before we learn that T Mysterio are
trying to get the Edith glasses the
first one of these comes during the
water attack in which we can see the
outline of the drums in the water Peter
is punched full force by hydro-man but
if you slow down the footage and look
really really closely you'll notice that
when Peter is hit the section of the
bridge that also gets hit doesn't
actually get wet it just explodes a bit
and then the water from the canal rises
up and that's what soaks everything
rather than being a blast from the punch
interesting right well there's also
another subtle hint that Mysterio is
fake when Peter is out on the roof after
being completely shut down by Nick Fury
I mean Tower I mean Talos during the
scene Mysterio flies in front of him but
in hindsight we know that this isn't
actually the character so how does he
end up sat next to Peter when the to go
to talk well as Peters
walking you will notice that the camera
pans from a doorway behind him which
also mimics someone walking from the
back to sit next to Peter and then
Mysterio joins him so I believe that
Mysterio was hidden at this point and
snuck behind him from the doorway and
sat on the ledge which is where the
illusion came together and allowed him
to take off his helmet another big hint
that everything is all an illusion comes
when Peter is fighting the fire
elemental and Nick Fury and Maria hill
arrive at the scene in their jeeps
during the attack there's a brief moment
where one of Mysterio's hand laser beam
dr. strange thingies hits the car but
instead of causing it to explode or be
melted all we see are bullet holes in
the windshield this clearly comes from
the drone and is in fact them just
firing at the car in order to make it
stop it's a nice little hint early on
that really is a blink and you'll miss a
moment that showcases just how much of
an illusion everything really was the
movie ends with Mysterio revealing the
identity of Peter to the world but it
was actually a setup for this earlier in
the film that shows Peter may have given
him the idea when coming up with excuses
for why he can't help fury the old
webhead says if I'm seen like this in
Europe after the Washington Monument my
whole class will figure out who I am and
then the whole world will figure out who
I am and then I'm done this was said in
front of Beck and it likely led to him
making the decision that he did in the
other post-credit scene we learn that
Nick Fury and Maria Hill actually
Scrolls in disguise whilst the real
versions are on vacation there were also
several clues that point towards this
throughout the film when Nick Fury tells
Peter that Mysterio is from the
multiverse he states that the character
is from earth just not yours if Nick was
from Earth then he would say he's from
Earth just not ours later in the movie
we hear him and Maria Hill discussing
Kree during one of their conversations
which lets you know that they too may
not be what they seem
Nick also hates the thought of Captain
Marvel being brought into it so yeah
he's a scroll the clues are all there in
the post-credits scene we catch a Nick
on a tropical beach which may be a
reference to Tahiti from agents of
shield it's a magical place I've heard
at one point in the film Peter meets
with Nick and he gets into a
top-of-the-range car the seatbelt on
this snaps quite easily
which makes fury give him a very stern
look later Peter falls out of the skies
Reaper after Mysterio's illusion comes
down and he hits a crappy beat-up
run-down car this is the same car that
he and fury pulled up in and it explains
why the seat belt broke so easily when a
hologram of Fury arrives it's given away
that he's fake as the police in the
background did not move now this film
shows Tony in quite a bad light by
making it seem like he was really bad to
his staff however there is potential
that they've all twisted what really
happened in their heads in order to
villainize him this is because in
Captain America Civil War the audience
is silent when Tony Stark says that the
project is called Baath however in
contrast in far from home when Tony says
this the audience will start laughing
this implies that Mysterio remembers it
differently and that the reality of it
wasn't nearly as bad another fun thing
in the film is Flash Thompson who has
the most hilarious bits of trivia in the
movie firstly his Instagram account is
called Spidey number one fan when he
does a stream we can also see that as
followers or pretty much all bots which
shows that he isn't as popular as he
thinks he is
when Peter Don's the Edith glasses and
looks around the bus we can see a
message from flash to his mother and
which he asks why his parents haven't
been in touch they failed to show up to
greet him at the airport so you can see
why would turn to fake followers and and
yeah I feel a bit bad for the guy now in
addition to this we can also see that
Dimitri's messages are encrypted and
this is because he works for Nick Fury
now the movie is absolutely packed with
Easter eggs and references to the comics
when happy Hogan and Peter talk we can
see a poster that is advertising a
wrestling match between crusher Hogan
and bone saw McGraw the former is who
Peter fought in the comics and the
latter is who Peter fought in the Sam
Raimi film spider-man when taking a
photograph they say pizza and you can
actually hear a character say Pizza time
very faintly which is a nod to
spider-man 2 also by Raimi Betty calls
her class Tigers which could be
referencing their mascot however it's
also likely a reference to Mary Jane
calling Peter tiger in the comics we
also see some fake films on the plane
including the snap which is directed by
Paul Greengrass he often makes films
based on real world events so it makes
sense that he would adapt the events of
the MCU
there's also finding Wakanda
which is funny because it's been hidden
for centuries hunting Hydra and noba
with dr. Erik Selvig there is of course
also ha to buy in the Tony Stark story
which may be a nod to the Iron Man
spin-off character iron heart on the
plane
Ned plays beast Slayers and he wins by
using a halberd
later in the film happy asks for a spear
and he corrects him by saying that's a
halberd there are several suits unhappy
ship that all pulled from the comics and
these have appeared in a number of
graphic novels including the original
iron spider design from the Civil War
series Marvel Zombies also get their own
nod with an undead Tony Stark appearing
in the film the spiders that crawl out
of his eyes yep you guessed it
black widows towards the end of the film
we also see a hint towards phase 4 and
it lets us know that there are a lot of
big things in store down the line I
can't wait to see what happens in phase
4 going forward
I'm just really hopeful that we actually
live long enough to see the movies
released happy days and that's our
entire list as always with the MCU I had
a hell of a lot of fun making this and I
hope you enjoyed it too obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
tidbits so comment below and let me know
if you want something else to watch that
makes you check out our breakdown of all
the insane details that we noticed in
avengers endgame there's some crazy
details in that so definitely check it
out after this every month on the 15th
we give away free blu-rays and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning the Star Wars Skywalker saga box
set it's comment below leave a like and
subscribe with notifications on if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early and please consider
clicking the join button below you can
also come chat to us on our discord
server or a definition whitey on Twitter
those are the best ways to keep up to
date with heavy spoilers so hopefully we
see over there very soon this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]